The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: All
right, so last time, we
were talking about degrees
of freedom in SCET.
And I drew these two pictures
and emphasized to you
that the difference
between these two pictures
is really where the degrees of
freedom live in momentum space.
So this is the P
minus P plus plane.
And unlike most
effective field theories,
in this effective
field theory we
have degrees of
freedom that have
to be identified by two
variables rather than just one.
So we need two variables
to say where collinears are
or where softs are.
And there was
generically, I said,
a dependence on the process.
So SCET, or what degrees
of freedom you need,
depends what you're studying.
And it's generically
not the case
that these two
effective theories
that I wrote down
for you will describe
every possible process.
In fact, SCET, of
course, won't describe
every possible process.
So what effective
field theory you need
depends on what
you're looking at.
It just turns out that these
two sets of degrees of freedom
that I wrote down
to you do describe
a lot of different processes.
And that's why the language
of SCETI and SCETII is useful,
but there's no guarantees.
You could run into a
process that requires
more degrees of freedom.
And there are
examples of processes
that require more degrees
of freedom than this,
but this is still a
useful starting point.
And this is where we'll start.
And then we were talking
a little bit about fields
last time.
And one thing I derived for
you was that the collinear
field has a power counting that
makes it scale like lambda.
This is the collinear quark.
And then at the end of lecture,
we also derived a formula
for the collinear gluons.
So if we write down components
of the collinear gluon plus,
minus, and perp--
we remember what
these notation means.
This means n dot A. And
this means n bar dot A.
And we figured out that
the scaling for these guys
is lambda squared 1 lambda.
And we said that that was
nice because we could put them
together with a derivative and
have a covariant derivative,
which I wrote in
terms of momenta just
to sort of emphasize.
So, if you like, this
is momentum space,
that these guys had
the same power counting
in the different components.
And so when we come and
talk about gauge invariance,
this fact that they have
the same power counting
in the different components
will, of course, be important.
Because what gauge invariance
does is ties momenta to gluons.
And if we didn't have
the same power counting
in the different
components, then we
would not have a gauge
field corresponding
to a certain momenta.
OK, so another way of
arguing that they should
have the same power counting
would have been directly
from gauge invariance.
All right, I'd like
to continue there.
The one thing that
you'll note, which
is unusual from an effective
theory point of view,
is there's a set of fields that
have no suppression at all.
These A n minus gluon
fields just scale like one.
So when you have
dimensional power counting,
all the fields have dimensions.
You add more fields.
You get higher dimensions.
You get suppression.
Here, with this
lambda power counting,
there's a component of the gauge
field that has no suppression.
We can add as many
of them as we want.
And that costs nothing.
So let's do that and
see what happens.
So a priori, you might think
that this is really bad
because you could have
an infinite number
of different operators
at lowest order
just with a different number
of these A n minus fields.
And we'll see that actually
things are not so bad,
but I think it's best to
do that by way of example.
So we'll consider an example
that just has one collinear
particle in it for simplicity.
And we can do that by
having a heavy particle that
carries a lot of energy
decay to a light particle,
like a B quark decaying
to an up quark.
So in QCD, our current
would just be u bar gamma b.
Gamma would be
left-handed current.
And we can consider the
B quark to be in HQET.
And we have an energetic u quark
as what we want to consider.
It's not the only
possibility, but we
could pump all the momentum
out through the current
into the leptons into the e nu.
But let's pump energy
into the up quark,
so that it's energetic.
So here's the current in QCD.
b goes to u.
And the notation that
I'll use for this
is a double line
for the heavy quark
and then a dashed line
for the collinear quark.
So this guy is going to be
described by an hv field.
This guy is going to be
described by Cn field.
This is production, so
this will be a Cn bar.
So I'll reserve this
notation of dashed lines
for collinear quark propagators.
OK, so the simple
minded thing is just
to write down an
effective theory current
where I replace the full theory
fields by the effective theory
fields.
I replace the up quark, an up
quark that's a Cn collinear
field in some direction.
And I replace the heavy quark
by an hv for the b quark.
Then, effectively, that would
be the tree level matching
between this diagram
and that diagram
or the tree level matching
from that particular diagram.
But let's consider adding
these A n minus gluons,
since they were things that
we could add to the current.
So we can add any number
of A n minuses here,
and we'd have something that's
the same order in the power
counting.
So let's consider another
diagram in QCD, where I just
attach an A n minus gluon.
And I'll attach it
to the heavy quark.
So I have a different
number of external fields,
but this one costs
me nothing when
I go to the effective theory.
Let's call this momentum here k.
We'll call this guy here q.
And this guy here
we'll just say is MbV.
So then k is MbV plus q.
And I can write q
out in components
since it's a collinear particle.
And if I want to
identify the big piece,
then that would be
the n bar dot qp's.
So remember last time, from
looking at coordinates,
we can write out any vector
in terms of the coordinates.
And it's useful to do that
since the coordinates have
a different power counter.
Now, what's going to
appear in the propagator
here is k squared minus m
squared minus Mb squared.
So let's look at k squared.
So if I square this term,
I just get Mb squared.
If I square this term, I
get 0, but then there's
a cross term as well.
And then there's some dots.
And the dots are indicating
terms that are suppressed.
And so if I look at k squared
minus M squared, then that's n
dot v Mb n bar dot q.
And this order lambda to the
0 since the momentum n bar
dot q was order lambda to the 0.
So there's no power
counting to the propagator.
Another way of saying
it is this propagator
is off-shell by a hard amount.
These scales are hard.
And if I go back
to my picture, that
means they're up here
in this purple region,
purple box around this.
OK, so the degree of freedom,
which is this purple propagator
is actually living up
in that purple region.
It's something we have
to integrate out, OK?
So let's do that.
So integrating it out just
means expanding the diagram.
And I've already
expanded the propagator,
so there's the denominators.
We just have to
expand the numerator.
OK.
Let me write out A n mu,
but we replace the spinner
by the field.
And I'll start by just writing
in the full propagator,
and then we'll
start expanding it.
I'm using a convention here for
the gluon interaction in QCD,
which is plus igTA gamma mu.
So there's the full theory.
All I've done is
take the full theory.
And rather than write spinners
and a polarization vector,
I've just written the fields.
Because I'm, in
the end, interested
in looking at what
kind of operator I get.
So I'm interested here in
taking the piece, which
is not suppressed.
So let's just do this slowly.
So there's an index A
on this guy as well.
So let's write out the leading
order piece of the numerator.
I've collected some i's,
put the M, the g out front.
So if I take all the order
1 pieces of the numerator,
then these are the
order 1 pieces.
Mb is order 1.
k I can replace by MbV plus q.
And then there's an MbV
slash that's order 1 and an n
slash over 2 n bar dot q.
That's the same decomposition
we had over there.
Here, because I'm interested
in certain polarization,
let me pull out
that polarization.
Then I have my denominator.
And my denominator
we already expanded,
so let's just write that in.
OK, so far, so good?
So this piece here is
0 because n squared
is 0. n slash
squared is n squared.
So then we have this piece.
For this piece, 1 plus
v slash, remember,
is part of a projector that
could act on the heavy quark.
But there's this n
slash in the way,
so we want to push it through.
So we can do that.
So let me write out the two
pieces from pushing it through.
There's an Mb that cancels
this Mb once that term's gone.
So let me do that.
When I push it through, I
switch to 1 minus v slash.
There's still a 1
over n dot v here.
And then there's an hv.
And 1 minus v slash on the
heavy quark field is 0.
And then the n dot
v cancels n dot v.
So if I want to
write this putting,
now, this A n field inside
because the TA is inside,
then I would write it like this.
So the momentum here n
bar dot q is order 1.
And this n bar dot
A n is order 1.
So this operator is the same
size as this operator here.
And that's what I was saying
that we should worry about,
the fact that we can add
these gluons without any cost.
And we just added
one and found out we
have an operative
that's the same order.
So the way you might draw this--
and there's a convention
also for collinear gluons
where you put a
line through them,
so this is a collinear gluon--
is that this guy is the
same order as this guy, OK?
Well, we'll come back to this,
talk more about it in a minute.
Let's consider another diagram.
We attached the
gluon on the left.
Let's also attach it on the
right, see what happens.
So again-- QCD diagram,
doing the same thing,
attaching the
gluon here, some q.
This is some momentum p.
And this is p minus q.
This case is different
than the previous case.
The reason that this
case is different
is that both p and
q are collinear.
And so p minus q is collinear,
too, same scaling as p and q.
So this propagator
is not off-shell.
In our hyperbolas, it would
live on the blue hyperbola
that I drew, which is well
within the effective theory,
not outside the
effective theory.
So we don't want to integrate
out this propagator here.
And what that means
is that there will be,
in the effective theory
itself, an interaction,
a Lagrangian interaction
that takes into
account this diagram.
So in the effective
theory, if you like,
if I draw an effective
theory diagram,
there will be an
effective theory diagram
that allows us to
attach that gluon
because this propagator
here is a propagator
in the effective theory.
Unlike the one that I just
erased which was off-shell
and had to be integrated
out of the effective theory,
this one is inside the
effective theory, OK?
So adding on the
left does something
different than
adding on the right.
On the left, we've knocked
the quark off-shell.
We add on the right,
it's close to mass shell.
So we can consider
generalizing what we just
did by adding more gluons.
Remember that we don't
have any restrictions
on how many we can add.
So let's just
consider adding more.
Let's add m of them.
And I'll call the
momenta q1, q2, to qm.
And all these propagators
here are off-shell.
This is a QCD graph.
When I calculate
graphs like this,
if I have these gluons there,
I have to also consider
cross-diagrams.
So rather than trying
to draw cross-diagrams,
let me just cross-gluon graphs.
And what you would expect
from what we've said before
is that in the
effective theory this
is going to catch on to
some kind of Feynman rule
that looks like
this, but then has
a bunch of gluons that can
come out of the vertex,
in this case m of them.
That's what we expect.
And so we expect
a generalization
of this operator with m
fields rather than just 1.
So if we do this
calculation, it actually
turns out to not
be too complicated.
I can include all cross-diagrams
by sum over permutations.
I have one of these n bar dot A
gluons for each external gluon
line with a corresponding
color factor.
And I keep the largest
piece of the denominator.
And I'm always just getting
the order 1 momenta.
And there's a
slight complication
that, when I have
a graph like this,
if I look at the momentum
of this, it's q1.
But if I look at the
momentum of the next one,
this would be q1 plus q2.
And so the denominators here are
not just simply q's, but sums
of q's.
OK.
And these n's would
be dotted into fields.
And T's would be
dotted into fields.
So if we want to write this as
an effective theory operator,
then we should think about
what this vertex means
in the effective theory.
And we should be a
little bit careful.
Because what this means,
if you think about it
in terms of the locality
of this diagram,
is that all these gluons are
coming out of the same point.
So it's like phi 4 theory where
you divide by 4 factorial.
You have to be a
little bit careful
because any one of these
gluons, from the point of view
of the external states,
could be as equally
good as an attachment.
So when we put in
the gluon fields,
we ought to be careful
about those factors.
So this is the
right Feynman rule.
And one way of just
thinking about it is we'll
have m of these fields, but then
we'll divide by an m factorial.
So we can write down the
complete result for the two
level matching as an
operator since we just
calculated all the diagrams.
So we started with this current.
We're in QCD.
And we matched it at
tree level onto a current
that I can write like this,
hiding all the complexity
in this thing I call
W. I have to sum
over however many attachments,
which I was previously calling
m, but now I'm calling k.
And if you study this guy for
a while, actually what is true
is that this guy has a name.
This is a momentum
space Wilson line.
So what is a position
space Wilson line?
That's where it really
looks more like a line.
So a Wilson line is a
string of gauge fields
that goes between
two points, here
between minus infinity and 0.
There are some
ordering to the fields
because they don't commute.
Because they're not abelian.
And the fact that
it's a line means
that we go in a straight
line between the two points.
So here's a path which
is a straight line
s between minus infinity and 0.
And actually, this formula here,
the Fourier transform of this,
is giving you the Wilson
line that I drew up--
the Feynman rule that I
drew up there or the fields
that I drew up there.
So there's some
ordering to the fields.
And what this P does
is it orders the fields
in an appropriate way.
Namely, it puts the guys
with the larger argument
to the left.
So on your homework,
you're going
to do the exercise of
thinking about doing
this matching for two gluons
and taking the Fourier transform
this and connecting these.
At least I believe
that's what I asked.
That's a very good exercise
to see everything work out
that I'm just describing
to you here in words.
So one way of thinking about
what's happened in this
effective theory-- and this
actually turns out to be
generically true--
is that rather than having
this embarked on a field, which
was order 1, it actually can
be traded for this Wilson line
object.
So I just showed you
that that happened
for this particular example,
but it turns out actually
to be genetic, that, instead
of talking about the n
bar of A field, we can
talk about this function
of the field, which
is this Wilson line.
Lift that for a sec.
So this is true
in this operator.
We just got this Wilson line.
In terms of the Wilson line,
things are pretty simple.
And it actually turns out
to be generically true,
and we'll see that later on.
And we'll also talk
about gauge invariance
later on, which has
to do with this story.
It turns out that this
Wilson line can also
be understood from the point
of view of gauge invariance.
The need for this
Wilson line can
be understood from the point
of view of gauge invariance.
And I can at least describe
that to you in words.
So if you look at
this diagram here,
we can't attach collinear
gluons to this quark.
But this carries color.
We can attach collinear gluons
to this quark, no problem.
It doesn't knock it
off-shell or anything.
So we're going to have a
problem with gauge symmetry
because we have two
things that are colored.
A priori, we're going to have
a problem with gauge symmetry
because we have two things
of color, one of which
we can't attach effective
theory fields to and one
of which we can.
But there's also operators
with gluons in them,
which are these ones.
And what effectively happens is
that the gauge transformation
that used to be for
this heavy quark field,
it gets moved into
this Wilson line.
So this Wilson
line will transform
in a way that compensates
for the transformation
of this collinear quark field.
And that's exactly because
the gluons here, which
were kind of the corresponding
gluons in QCD for the gauge
transformation, are
explicitly integrated out
to give that Wilson line.
So it's all tied together.
We'll come back and talk about
that in more detail later.
All right, so let's consider
now the effective theory now
that we have some idea of how
these calculations are working.
And let's consider this
SCETI effective theory.
So we have a collinear mode and
an ultra soft mode with momenta
that we're scaling in this way.
And we also know, if we
consider the Feynman rules,
we can look at what the
propagators would look like.
So let's consider, first of
all, having a collinear gluon.
And let's just try to think
about what kind of propagators
the effective theory
is going to have.
So maybe this comes
from a heavy quark.
So we have this possibility
of having a collinear gluon,
momentum q.
We expanded the propagator
for that last time.
And the important point about
this being a collinear gluon
is that p and q
are the same size.
So we never drop p relative
to q or q relative to p.
So if we write out
the components,
we did this last time.
And we found that
there was really
no expansion in the denominator.
And in the numerator, we
could make an expansion
and just keep the
leading order piece.
So the propagator would
be proportional to this.
There's some spin structure
as well that I'm not writing.
But q of the gluon is
of order p of the quark.
So nothing gets dropped.
So this is going to
be a propagator that
exists in the effective theory.
That's what I was saying before.
The other thing we
could do is we could
attach an ultra soft particle.
We could actually attach
it to either side,
but let me focus
on the right side.
So there's going to be
some ultra soft gluon.
It's not collinear
to any direction.
Let's call its momenta
k, call this still p.
Now, k is much smaller than
p by our power counting.
So the k is of order
lambda squared.
So in n bar dot k is
much less than n bar dot
p, which is of order lambda 0.
k perp is much less than p
perp, which is of order lambda.
And then the n dot
k is or order n
dot p because those are
both lambda squared.
So here it's not going
to be like over there.
There is actually going
to be an expansion that
occurs because things
are of different size.
So if I only keep the leading
order terms and the propagator
here, well, the numerator
I just have n bar
dot p because n
bar dot k is small.
And the only place that
I need to keep both
is in this n dot term.
So there is an
expansion that goes on.
And again, if I look at how
off-shell this propagator is,
it's perfectly within
the effective theory.
So this is a propagator with
off-shellness that leaves it
inside the effective theory.
OK.
So it's not far
off-shell by any means.
In fact, it's just as off-shell
as the propagator over there
for the collinear particles.
So it doesn't really
make sense to think
about treating this propagator
any different than treating
this propagator from an
effective theory point of view.
But you see that
the Feynman rule
has to somehow know whether
you're in this situation where
you need to keep the
momentum of the gluon
or whether you're in this
situation where the momentum
should be expanded.
And we'll see how that works.
So this is by way of
sort of giving you
a hint as to what's to come
and what kind of complications
we'll face in the
effective theory
because the effective theory can
interact with collinear gluons
or these ultra soft gluons.
And it somehow needs to be only
keeping leading order terms.
If it's really the leading
order effective theory, then
we should just keep this term.
We shouldn't keep these
higher order terms.
But over here, we have
to keep all the terms.
So what should the leading
order effective theory do?
What should we demand of it?
We've basically, now,
set up all the things
that we need to
think about in order
to figure out what the leading
order effective theory is.
So let's do that.
OK, so what do we demand
of this Lagrangian?
It should yield the
propagator of course
and, also, interactions.
Within this effective
theory, it has interactions
both with collinear gluons
in that diagram over there
and with ultra soft gluons.
And you can see
even from here why
we need two different
fields because there
has to be some way
of telling that we
have a different propagator in
this case than in that case.
Or put another way,
the external field
here has a different
power counting
than the external field here.
So already we're kind
of seeing that we
need two different gluon fields
in this effective theory,
as we said earlier.
So the Lagrangian has to have
interactions with both of them.
It has to have both
quarks and antiquarks
because remember that
collinear quarks and collinear
antiquarks both existed
as leading order things.
That's not like HQET where one
of them gets integrated out.
And basically, that
is just the statement
that, say you have a collinear
gluon going along very quickly.
It can para-- create a
quark and an antiquark.
And if they're,
again, collinear,
that's something that has to
be allowed to happen at order
1 in this effective theory.
OK.
So, so far, so good.
This is just saying,
what kind of fields
are we going to have
in this Lagrangian.
This third bullet is related
to what I was just stressing,
that we have to get a
leading order propagator
in different situations.
So somehow the
effective theory has
to know something about
the size of momenta that
are running through it.
And if we want to be
strict about defining
the effective theory and just
defining the leading order
term, it's not OK
that we expand later.
We really have to
expand ahead of time.
And so whatever the Lagrangian
is, it should just give this.
And it should just give this.
And it should not
give these dots, OK?
So that's what I mean by
having no additional expansion.
And the final thing is
a little more subtle.
And that is that we
should think ahead.
So when we design
this effective theory,
we're not only going to want
to describe the leading order
term, but we're
also going to want
to describe power corrections.
Because if we can't describe
the power corrections,
we don't really have an
effective field theory.
So whatever we do,
we should make sure
that we have a notion of what's
going on with higher order
terms, that they're
well-defined things, that we
can think ahead about what
the operators are going
to look like.
And we need that
in order to know
that we can formulate those
operators and make sure
they're suppressed.
So another way of putting it is
that we should set things up,
so we don't have
to re-set things up
when we start talking
about power corrections.
So we really should think about
the effective theory globally
even though we're sort of
starting by formulating
a leading order term.
We should think about the
power corrections as well
and how those interactions
are going to behave.
OK, so that's saying that
we want to think about,
at least, what
these dots are going
to look like, what
this plus dot,
dot, dot is going to look like.
OK, so this is our goal.
And we'll go through it slowly.
So this is a top-down
effective theory.
So we can start with
QCD, and then we
can integrate out the
off-shell degrees of freedom.
We can just formulate
from what SCET
is by starting with
the QCD Lagrangian
and splitting it into
the fields that we want
and manipulating it.
So let's start with
psi bar iD slash psi.
And let's write psi in
terms of two fields.
And this goes back
to our discussion
when we were talking
about spinners.
So these two fields have a
projector on the full theory
field, and they obey n bar
slash, n slash, n slash,
n bar slash.
Cn is Cn.
And the n bar slash n
slash by n bar is by n bar.
So I want to write out the
QCD Lagrangian in terms
of component because the
different derivatives,
the different components
of the covariant derivative
and the different
regular derivatives
inside that derivative, have
different power counting, OK?
So let's do that.
And I'll introduce these two
fields in order to do that.
So if you like, I'm just taking
QCD and writing it in these
coordinates that we're
setting our usual coordinates
for talking about SCET.
So decompose the D
slash and just write out
the field as these two pieces.
And then I can
multiply these out.
And because of the
projection relation,
some of these
products will vanish.
So if I only write the
pieces that don't vanish,
then I only have four
pieces, which are these four.
So all other combinations
that I didn't write
vanish, and those four survive.
We'll do one example,
so you see what
the strategy is for getting
rid of the other terms.
So let's consider one
of the other terms.
Let's consider the guy
with the D perp slash,
but between two Cn fields.
So I can insert the projector.
And then I can move it
through the D perp slash.
I'm moving two things
through, and they both
have 0 dot product with D perp.
So there's no additional terms.
I just can push it through.
And n slash on Cn bar is 0.
So n slash on Cn
was 0, remember.
And if you take the dagger and
make it into a bar relation,
you also have this formula.
So this is 0.
And a similar thing--
by inserting projectors,
we can figure out
which terms are non-0.
And these ones I'm writing
are the non-0 ones.
This guy's 0.
That's why I didn't write it.
OK, so any questions so far?
Hot today, drink lots of water.
OK.
This is just QCD.
I haven't done anything.
I just write QCD out and assign
some strange coordinates.
So now, I'm going to
do one thing, which
is going to end up simplifying
our lives a little bit later
on.
And I'm going to use the
fact that, when we talked
about production
of quarks, we said
we're going to produce
this Cn type of quark
and not the phi n bar
bar type of quark.
So phi n bar,
remember, corresponded
to sub-leading
spinner components.
So let's just decree
that I don't really
care about this field.
And, therefore, I don't need
to have any current in my path
integral that I
couple to this guy.
So it's like an auxiliary
field if you like.
And because the path integral
in this fermionic field
is quadratic, we can just
remove it from the path,
just do the path
integral over it.
Once we know that there's
no source term for it,
we can just do the path
integral since all the terms are
explicitly written over there.
So let's see what
happens when we do that.
So doing the path integral
for this quadratic field just
means solving the
equations of motion.
So we take the variational
derivative with respect
to phi n bar of the Lagrangian.
And that gives us the
following equation.
We could multiply both
terms in this equation
by an n bar slash over 2.
And then we can use the
projection relation.
Just to simplify the
Dirac structure a little,
we can move the Dirac
structure from here to here.
And then we could formally solve
this equation for the phi n
bar.
It's an inverse
covariant derivative.
I can push this through
this at the cost of a sign.
So if I move it to
the right-hand side
of the equation, that
takes care of that sign.
So I did two sign changes.
I moved something to the right.
And then I pushed these
through each other
to get that equation.
OK.
So what this is saying, in
terms of the original field,
is that I have this
equation for psi.
So if we take that
result and we plug it
back into our Lagrangian,
which I meant to give a star,
then we'll just have an
equation in terms of the C.
We already used two terms.
And so those two terms,
when you plug it back in,
they just cancel.
So there was two terms
in the Lagrangian
that had psi n bar bar.
And the remaining
two you have that.
OK, so this is Lagrangian that's
just in terms of the Cn field.
We'll call it double star.
Previous guy was
supposed to be star.
OK, so several questions arise.
What have we done?
Do we like this inverse
covariant derivative?
Are we happy with that?
Are we unhappy with it?
So what does an inverse
covariant derivative mean?
Well, actually just what is
an inverse derivative mean?
This is an inverse operator.
So what does that mean?
So the way you define
an inverse operator
is exactly how you define
in quantum mechanics.
So let me remind you of that.
This is the analog of, in
quantum mechanics, having, say,
a 1 over r potential.
But if r is an operator, then
you have a 1 over an operator.
And the way that you define
that is by the eigenvalues.
So 1 over i in r dot
partial of some field
i of x you can write it out
in terms of momentum space.
So if we go over to momentum
space, that's the eigenbasis.
And then the
eigenvalue is just 1
over the momentum, this
component of the momentum.
OK, so it's just the
Fourier transform of that.
So this is [INAUDIBLE].
Yup.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have a question
about whether or not
you've actually done nothing.
IAIN STEWART: I have
done nothing, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
seems [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
that's my next comment.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And so phi n bar--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: Actually corresponding
to this other new spinner
would mean that you're only
considering interactions
that are all collinear.
In the original
piece, the [INAUDIBLE]
does contain that interaction.
IAIN STEWART: The
only difference
between what I've done so
far in QCD is that, in QCD,
if we were to think
about QCD, we'd
couple external currents both
to this phi n bar as well
as the Cn.
And that's the only difference.
But there's a small
community of people
that actually think
about this Lagrangian
as the QCD Lagrangian.
And that's because, if I
was willing to a couple
a current to this particular
combination of fields,
I could still call it QCD, OK?
So in that sense,
if I really demand
that I'm only producing
Cn's and I just
have a term that's, like, JCn
and I don't have this phi n
bar, then it's
something different
because I'm not directly
able to produce these guys.
But if I allow myself,
also, to couple
to this combination here,
then I can do everything
in terms of these Cn fields.
And it's really just QCD.
AUDIENCE: So star star
is exactly collinear QCD
if you're only producing in--
IAIN STEWART: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --forward
direction or something?
[INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Just even
simpler, it's exactly
QCD if I only produce these Cn.
If I just say I'm
only interested
in operators that produce this
particular spin component--
AUDIENCE: But if you
try to say that--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: No, no.
I haven't I haven't
made any expansion
to make it collinear yet.
AUDIENCE: But if there was a
hard scatter with two totally
different directions
[INAUDIBLE],,
you could produce
phi n bars, right?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, but that
would be another Lagrangian.
So this Lagrangian,
in the end, will only
be useful for
producing particles
in the n collinear direction.
That's what I'm
going to be after.
And I'd have another
copy of this.
For each linear direction,
I have one additional copy
of what I'm doing now.
AUDIENCE: Right, so
you've lost the ability
to produce hard
scattering by doing this.
IAIN STEWART: By
just doing this.
AUDIENCE: But as long
as you don't talk about
that, it's still [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Right.
That's right.
OK.
So we're far from done.
And really this is
just sort of a warm up.
Really what we've done here is
we've just written things out
in terms of components.
And it's true that
these derivatives here
have different power counting.
And we're going to make
use of that in a second.
And we've also just sort
of focused our attention
on this guy that
we could produce
at leading order from
a hard scattering
in some particular direction,
such as in our b to u example.
So if we're interested in
just one collinear direction,
then there's two components
of the spinner that
are always the big components.
And we focused on a field
that gives those components
directly.
So what do we have to do still?
So there's three more steps.
So we have to
separate collinear.
So far, we just have one
type of covariant derivative.
We have to separate
out the fields that are
in that covariant derivative.
In particular, the ultra soft
and collinear gauge fields
have to be separated out.
Another thing we
have to do is we
have to separate the collinear
and ultra soft momenta.
There's two different
types of momenta,
as we saw in this simple
example of a gluon momenta
flowing into a propagator.
And we actually have
to distinguish them.
And then we have to expand.
So until we do these
first two steps,
there's not really
anything to expand.
And so once we've
distinguished those,
we'll be able to say
that certain things are
larger than others.
And then we'll be
able to figure out
what the leading or
Lagrangian actually is.
OK, so let's start
with this second step.
So this is step two.
So remember what the
power counting was.
The collinear gluons
had this scaling.
The ultra soft gluons
had this scaling,
which is the same as
an ultra soft momenta.
And the right way of
doing this kind of thing
would be to take
Feynman diagrams
and do some matching
calculations,
but sometimes we're
able to get away
with just thinking about
doing things by writing down
field relations.
And that's almost true here.
When we were drawing our
Feynman diagrams before,
if you think about one gluon,
this is certainly true.
So we drew Feynman
diagrams before.
We had this one, and we had
this one, ultra soft collinear.
And we just consider
one at a time.
So we could just
think of adding them.
And that's kind of almost true.
It turns out that it's
true up to some terms
that we don't care about
for the moment, OK?
But these terms are
power suppressed.
And we'll see where
they come from later on.
So the way you can
think about this,
if you ignore that
complication, is
that you really just divide the
gauge field into two pieces.
There's one place that you've
perhaps seen that before,
when you talk about a
background gauge field, right?
You say you have a quantum
field and a background field.
And that's very nice if you
go to background field gauge.
And that's kind of
physically what's
going on here because we
have two different modes that
have different wavelengths.
These guys are really
long wavelength.
These guys are
shorter wavelength.
Remember that the p
squared of these guys
is much larger than the
p squared of these guys.
And think about this
formula in that way,
that this is like a
classical background
field to the Cn and the A n mu
since the p ultra soft squared
had a scaling which was lambda
to the fourth lambda squared
squared.
And that's much smaller than
p collinear squared, which
was q squared lambda squared.
So that's saying that this guy
has much larger wavelength,
a long wavelength mode to
these short distance modes.
So we can think of this
as a slowly varying
classical background.
And that's one way of
thinking about this formula.
We'll exploit that a little
bit later on as well.
So now that we have
the sum of them,
we can just think about how big
one is relative to the other.
And actually, the coefficient
that's between them
doesn't really matter
too much for that.
So let's think about
the power counting
I already wrote on the board.
So the power counting
is that n bar
dot A n is order lambda
to the 0 and so is
much greater than the
n bar dot A ultra soft,
which is order lambda squared.
Same for A perp n,
that's of order lambda.
That's much greater
than A perp ultra soft.
And so those two formulas
mean that it would never
have a comparison
between this and this.
I can always drop
the smaller one.
And just like our
momentum, there's
one case where
that's not true where
we have to keep both of them.
And that's for the
n dot A component.
So here's something
we can drop, n bar
dot A ultra soft and
A perp ultra soft.
That leading order
can be dropped, OK?
So that's what we're
going to do and step two.
Step three corresponds
to dropping momentum
relative to another momentum.
So there was an expansion
of the propagator
in the case where we had
an ultra soft and collinear
at the same time.
And let's just write
that down again,
but let's keep the
next order term.
And I'll ignore the
numerator since just looking
at the denominator will
give us enough information
for this discussion.
We could do the numerator, too.
It would just lead
to more terms.
So there are some terms
that I can expand.
And then I get the
propagator squared,
or I get a P squared squared,
because I expanded something
in the denominator back
into the numerator.
So the next order term
comes from a dot product
in the perp momenta because
the Pn perp is large.
And so we get a term with
two k ultra soft dot Pn perp
that corrects the
leading order term.
And that's the first
sub-leading term.
So if you think about the
power counting of these,
this guy is lambda
to the minus 2.
And this guy is
lambda to the minus 1.
OK, so there has to be something
in the effective theory that,
at higher order, will
reproduce this second guy.
There will be some power
suppressed Feynman rule in SCET
to reproduce this second term.
So what that means is
that you can't just
think that you ignore
this guy completely,
this k ultra soft perp.
You might just say, well, I just
set all the k ultra soft perps
and the k ultra
soft minuses to 0.
And that would be
something that you
can get away with, if your
careful, at lowest order.
But at sub-leading
order, you can't.
You need to think
that they exist, too.
So whatever formalism we develop
should not set them to 0.
And that was one of my
bullets that you should
think a little bit ahead.
And this is me thinking
ahead, that I'm not
going to be able to just set
those momentum exactly to 0.
I'm going to need them
when I start talking
about sub-leading terms.
OK, so we expand just
like we don't throw away
the sub-leading gauge
fields because we need those
at sub-leading order as well.
We neglect them in
the leading order,
but we have to sort of
think that they exist still.
And with momenta, it's
a little different
since fields carry momenta.
And so what you should think
is that the fields are allowed
to sort of carry these
momenta, but the Feynman rules
of the leading order theory
are just not sensitive to them.
And that's the right
way of thinking.
OK, so what we need
is an expansion
of the theory that will do this.
And that's called the
multipole expansion.
So let me remind
you of some things
about multipole expansion.
Well, a multipole expansion
you see in electromagnetism,
remember?
You look at a charge
distribution far away.
You see the total interval
over that charge distribution
and then the dipole.
That's the usual
thing that you think
of when you think of the
words multipole expansion.
You think of E&M. And
it's similar here,
except we're doing
it for fields.
So in position space, it's
similar to this where we expand
and we neglect some coordinates.
So let me show you how a
multipole expansion works
in one dimension
in position space.
So let's consider the following.
Consider an integral
dx psi bar of x A
of 0 psi bar of psi of x.
So one of the fields I
stuck at 0 I expanded out
the coordinate around 0, whereas
the other ones I kept the x.
Let's see what this does
for the momentum space
by Fourier transforming it--
so some momenta,
some phases, and then
some momentum space vehicles.
And I just put 0
because I put one
of the fields in the
coordinate space at 0.
Do the x integral.
So I got a delta function
that says P1 is equal to P2
because I didn't have
anything in the k.
And this is kind of along
the lines of what we want.
It says that the momentum P1
is equal to the momentum P2.
And that's like expanding in k.
So if we think about having
some Feynman diagram where
we have P1 and P2
and some k coming in,
if we want in some component
that P1 is equal to P2,
then this is achieving that.
OK, so this is the
analog of the kind
of expanding coordinates
that you do in E&M. Expanding
into coordinates of a field
is doing the same thing.
It's giving a
momentum conservation
that ignores the momentum
conjugate to that
coordinate that I expand in.
So what would the next
order term look like?
So we're still here
in one dimension.
If you think about
the expansion,
the next order term would
be a term like this,
then at x equals 0.
Sorry.
I don't really need dot
since this is one dimension.
So that would be the next
term in a Taylor series
of the field about x equals 0.
And if you do the same thing,
Fourier transform this guy,
you can work out that
you get the following.
OK, so the derivative
here on the coordinate,
that comes with k, momentum.
Because I should Fourier
transform the field,
then take the derivative,
then set the coordinate to 0,
so I can still get a k.
And this x actually just ends
up leading to a delta prime.
You can write it
as a derivative.
And x can be written as a
derivative in momentum space.
And then it's a derivative
on the delta function.
OK, so that's what the second
order term would look like.
So if you were to
think like this,
you have some kind
of Feynman rule
that's proportional
to a delta prime.
And then however you
deal with a delta prime,
if you're Feynman rule had a
delta prime, what you would do
is you would integrate by parts.
And then the delta
prime would start taking
derivatives of other things.
So that is a possible
route, but we're not
going to take that route.
We're going to do
something simpler.
So we could formulate the
multipole expansion in position
space like that,
but we're actually
going to formulate
it in momentum space.
So we're going to
do the same thing,
but we're going to do
it in momentum space.
What are some
reasons to do that?
Well, when you do
Feynman diagrams,
you do them in momentum space.
So if we've already formulated
things in momentum space,
then we'll immediately
get the Feynman rules
we want to do loop integrals
and stuff like that.
So that's an advantage of the
momentum space is that you more
directly get the
Feynman rules you want
and the diagrams in
the form you want.
It simplifies, actually,
slightly the formulation
or somewhat the formulation
of gauge transformations,
which we'll talk about later on.
And what I think is a
nice kind of advantage
is where the momentum expansion
sits is in the propagator,
not in the vertices.
We don't get Feynman
rules with delta primes,
but we then have to integrate
by parts to understand.
We just immediately
get insertions
on propagators which would
correspond to the derivatives
that I would take
from integrating
that delta prime by parts.
So this term that we saw before
that looked like a propagator
squared--
which was when we were
sitting in momentum space
and we expanded the
propagator to second order.
So we had this term that was
ultra soft perp dot Pn perp.
And then it had this
denominator that was squared.
If you ask where in
the effective theory
is that, what is going to be the
thing that corresponds to that,
it's going to correspond to
some collinear propagator
with an insertion on it.
And the insertion
gives this numerator.
And then I have two propagators.
And that gives the
two denominators.
OK, so that's how that term
is going to come about.
So there will be some
sub-leading Lagrangian
that I could call L1 that I
can insert on the propagator.
And that would give rise to
these terms that we were saying
were higher order.
OK, so we have to figure
out how to do this.
And I will just give a little
bit of a picture for it today,
and then we'll continue
with it next time.
So I'm going to have
to back up a bit.
So let's back up to the
Lagrangian that we had before.
And I want to just
introduce, since we were not
close to being done--
we had sort of started down the
path, but we weren't done yet.
Let me give a slightly
different name to this field.
Let me put a hat on it.
So I want to do the
expansion in momentum space.
So let me Fourier transform.
So I'll call psi n twiddle of
P, do the full Fourier transform
of this guy, which was
previously just a field x.
And we'll think about
doing expansions
in this momentum space field.
And for now, I'm also going to
make one other simplification.
And that is to only
consider the quark part.
And we'll put the
antiquarks back in later.
So if you like, we're
considering sort of the a's and
not the b's in the
decomposition of the field.
OK, so let's think
about this and think
about how we can do an
expansion that would correspond
to this multipole expansion.
And the analogy that I'm
going to exploit here,
although it's not
perfect, is the expansion
that we did in HQET.
So in HQET, we said we had a
full momentum for the b quark.
And we split it into a piece,
which is kind of the big piece.
And then we had a piece
that was the small piece.
And I'm going to do
something similar in SCET.
I'm going to say I
have a full momentum--
I'm going to move
the indices up--
that I'm going to split into
two pieces because of the power
counting, a big piece
and a small piece.
The big piece here
will be the terms which
were of order 1 or lambda.
And then the rest
here will be something
that's of order lambda squared.
And I allow that
residual piece not
just to be in the
plus direction,
but to be in any direction.
Because remember, at
sub-leading orders,
I'm going to have to care about
the other components as well.
So let me just say
that the residual could
have order lambda squared
pieces in any component.
In the minus and
the perp, I'm going
to expand with these residuals
being smaller than these terms
here.
And this momentum I'm going
to call a label momentum.
to call residual momentum.
We'll see why that's a
good language next time,
but it's kind of connected to
the idea that, in the HQET,
we labeled the fields
by this V. And we're
going to see that, for at
least some of the interactions,
it's a reasonable
way of thinking.
These large momentum is
just labels on the fields.
OK, so we'll talk more
about that next time.
I think I don't want
to go further with it.
But basically, we're going to
make an expansion in residuals
being smaller than these guys.
And in order to
make that expansion,
I have to have some notation
for the different pieces.
And we'll see where
that leads us next time.
It'll effectively lead
us to the same thing
as this multipole expansion
in position space,
but it's a little
nicer, I claim.
I like it a little more.
Questions?
Good.